[Music]
Owen and Demitri thank you for joining
us on spectator TV um Owen you wri in
the magazine this week that the war in
Ukraine can now only end with a peace
deal um when did you think it became
sort of clear that that Ukraine couldn't
s of win this war outright and that and
that a compromise would have to be
reached with with
Russia uh well um this was clear
immediately from the beginning that uh
Ukraine was more or less I mean it's the
full defeat of Russia and the removal of
the Putin regime um would be a nice goal
but actually you know it's the nuclear
biggest nuclear armed power in the world
um if we're talking about defeating
Russia in the sense of actually you know
defeating it comprehensively as you know
Germany and Japan were defeated in 1945
that was never really going to happen um
the the thing that's been unclear up to
this point is how far the the ukrainians
would be able to get in terms of their
counter offensive in terms of pushing uh
Putin's troops out of the territory they
occupied since um February of last year
and um that's I think what's changed
over the last month particularly with
the Ukrainian Comm um chief of general
staff um Val is alusion announcing in
The Economist last month that there was
not going to be a magical breakthrough
um and I think
the there are um officially um several
of the senior people that I spoke to
zalinsky people that I spoke to in Kiev
over the last couple of weeks uh believe
still that they'll be able to do for
better in a spring offensive but um
frankly I'm not sure how that's going to
happen because they don't have air
superiority even if they do get f-16s
they're not really going to achieve the
same the the kind of overwhelming air
super superiority that they need for a
massive breakthrough and they're
basically going to be in the same
situation as they are now which is
fighting through a very deep and uh
comprehensively defended uh barrier of
um trenches and minefields and so on so
the idea that Ukraine is actually going
to you know realistically throw Putin
out of its territory entirely is now I
think pretty much off the cards Demetri
do you think now is a good time to cut a
deal no I I do agree with uh Owen though
that at some point there will be
negotiations almost every War uh in
history uh or certainly modern history
has ended in negotiations and not
unconditional surrenders and no one
thinks that Russia will will take an
unconditional surrender or you could
force them to the problem however is
that this war has never really been
about territory for for either side um
in the case of Vladimir Putin territory
is not really what he's primarily
focused on he doesn't really care that
much if he takes the town of bahmut as
he did this year or if he takes the
village or small town of adfa that's not
his primary goal his primary goal is to
control Ukraine um his original goal of
course was Maximus to install a puppet
regime in in Kiev um but at a minimum he
wants to make sure that Ukraine is torn
away from the Western Alliance beat NATO
beat EU and general affiliation with the
West territorial the irony is that the
territorial Conquest does not accomplish
that objective that the more he takes
the donbas does not make uh Kev want
want to be part of Russia or be part of
Russia's um orbit and on the Ukrainian
side even though they obviously want to
get back their territory and even more
importantly get back their people that
is also not the primary objective the
primary objective when I talk to people
in Kiev is to make make sure that this
country um is secure and safe for
Generations that Russia will not do
again to it what it has done um since
2014 which is invade uh terrorized its
people occupy its lands and I think they
would actually take a deal that gives up
at least some of the territory if not
officially then sort of acquiescing to
it if they could ensure that they could
get those security guarantees be it
primarily their interests in NATO of
course Russia would never allow that
deal to happen happen because again
their focus is not primarily territory
it's to prevent Ukraine from having that
Safety and Security of NATO because
Russia wants to dominate it so I don't
just don't see what kind of deal is
possible and the the challenge that I've
always had with this counter offensive
is even if it had been wildly successful
if you can sort of Imagine a scenario
where Ukraine takes back every inch of
its territory including Crimea including
the Dan Bas that would not have resulted
in the War ending all that would have
done is mve the front line to the
Ukraine's internationally recognized
borders in fact the Russians would not
have only not Not only would not have
said well that's it we're giving up
we're going back um uh into Russian
territory and giving up on terrorizing
Ukraine they probably would have
mobilized it probably would have um uh
taken even uh wor actions to to destroy
Ukrainian infrastructure and make life
much harder for the Ukrainian people so
at the end of the day I think we are
unfortunately settled in um as we had
really since April of last year into
this long War rtion in some ways you can
think about this war as having gone on
for 10 years almost since 2014 uh in
various iterations and I think
unfortunately it could go on for many
years to come not necessarily at the
same level of intensity of combat um but
I just don't see the prospects of
negotiations anytime soon particularly
with Vladimir Putin thinking that he's
got an upper hand I mean I mean in your
piece you mentioned that there was a
point when peace talks were ongoing and
it seemed like that deal could be
reached back in back in March uh 2022 I
mean can you tell us a bit about that
yeah first I must I must say that I'm
I'm completely shocked that I find
myself in strong agreement with you
Demitri pretty much everything you say
Yes um uh well with the talks um in a
nutshell there's a kind of dangerous and
easy narrative that was uh that is
current in um some Western political
circles um not really in Ukraine but
definitely that's part of the western uh
the you know particularly Ukraine
skeptic uh narrative in the West that um
we made rash promises particularly Boris
Johnson when he arrived in Kiev on 9th
of April 2022 um
of basically unlimited support for
Ukraine and that was the proximate cause
for those series of negotiations that
happened in Minsk then antalia than
Istanbul to collapse um but in fact I
think um having spoken to a lot of the
principles um it was pretty clear that
by the end of April Sorry by by the
beginning of April um there was not
really any sign that the Russians were
willing to make a deal that would have
been acceptable to Ukraine in any way
shape or form so I the easy thing would
would be to say the ukrainians could
have accepted the loss of land and
neutrality and that would have been the
end of the war but actually the Russians
wanted much more than that that they
wanted um uh essentially the Ukraine to
sort of formerly concede uh control over
uh the Russian occupation of of of the
donbass and uh most importantly to agree
to restrictions on their military and um
by that point electorally within Ukraine
um already the horrific images from bcha
andin and all the massacres so already
you know by the time the last time when
Vladimir zinski talked about
negotiations that was actually on April
9th 2022 just a few hours before Johnson
came that was the last time he mentioned
it and that was actually after Bucher
already but already it was pretty clear
there was a sort of landslide of horror
and revulsion from the Ukrainian public
opinion and so uh but on the other hand
you know the bigger picture is that the
deal that's on the table now is not a
million miles away from the deal that
was on the table in April 22 except
there are two really fundamental
differences and that is that I think
that it's going to be extremely
difficult for the ukrainians to accept
neutrality and they're very in adamant
about full NATO membership and secondly
uh they're not going to accept any
restrictions on the you know on the
military um as for the status of donbass
and crier as Demitri rightly said I
think actually that's not really the the
The crucial part it's um it's really
about you Ukraine's alignment and that
begs a really crucial question to which
I don't really have an answer and that
is is Ukraine joining NATO going to make
Ukraine more secure or less secure and
you know what is so terrible about
Ukraine being a formerly neutral country
like as Finland was from 1940 until it's
joined NATO uh and Sweden was and by the
way also Austria is and um Switzerland
and and Ireland I mean there's lots of
European countries that are forly
neutral but nonetheless have strong
security guarantees from NATO so uh I
think the question going forward is kind
of an existential one uh for NATO as
much as for Ukraine does the Ukrainian
logic that only full membership of NATO
guarantee their security does that
theory hold water or is actually a some
kind of association with the West with
EU membership but not actual full
membership of NATO but with strong
security guarantees from NATO Partners
is that going to be feasible and and is
that going to be politically acceptable
for Ukraine that's a really interesting
question I mean Demitri what do you
think I mean the the plenty of people
could say to Ukraine you know you're
never going to be a member of NATO not
while you have disputed borders with
Russia um why not promise Russia that
you won't join up because it's not going
to happen anyway I mean what do you do
you subscribe to that view well again
the key thing for Ukraine is how do they
get um safety and security and
assurances that Russia will not invade
again I think they would take something
less than NATO memberships membership if
they could get those security guarantees
from NATO um but the challenge of course
is that the reason that they um are not
able to join NATO is precisely because
no one is willing to extend them those
security guarantees primarily Article 5
um yes there are issues with Ukrainian
modernization and being able to
integrate with NATO but the primary
reason why their objections to them
joining today from both Washington and
the other side of the Atlantic in Europe
is because uh of the belief um that I
think is correct of the dangers of
extending Article Five um sort of all
for one and one for all security
guarantees to Ukraine that could
potentially bring NATO into conflict
with Russia so even if you do not let
Ukraine join NATO but extend some
similar sort of protection real security
guarantees not what was offered to them
in 1994 which of course was not security
guarantees at all but basically a
promise that um their territorial
Integrity would not be violated which
Russia of course did um and an
obligation by others to Simply bring
this up in the security Council um um if
such a violation occurs um um but real
security guarantees then you know it's
basically the equivalent of NATO and you
have the fundamental problem again that
it would bring um whoever offers those
security guarantees whether it's us
alone or some combination of um European
countries and the us into a potential
conflict with Russia which they want to
avoid at all costs so that remains the
fundamental issue and by the way from
Russia's perspective it's not really
about NATO it's again because Putin's
goal is to dominate Ukraine and
ultimately tear Ukraine away from its um
Western affiliation um he doesn't want
to see any security guarantees be it
NATO or otherwise that would allow NATO
to be I mean Ukraine to be free uh from
uh fear of conquest by Russia and
control by Russia so you have these
diametrically oppos maximalist
objectives on both sides I mean Ukraine
is obviously very reasonable and wanting
to protect its country from further
invasions and the Russians wanted to
have the option to execute further
invasions um so that's why I don't see
um a deal here um that would be
palatable to either Moscow or Kev thank
you Dimitri thank you
[Music]
ow